[Music]
I mean usually I don't have nothing in
my pockets cuz you know I heard
somewhere that gentlemen don't have
anything in their pocket in my pocket I
have a phone obviously it's quite a big
phone people make fun of me to speak but
I do everything this phone I also have a
cell phone I don't use I tend to lose it
a lot this is a new one I knew used one
you always get new phone
[ __ ] inside I have the bad thing with
phones and computers and cars and my
metal star yeah I cannot live without my
phone I even got my initials so I know
it's mine was laying around and even
nice because it has like a sipper soap
and they don't want to carry it around
in my back
also my just on me ma che me Danny
backpack so legal civilization started
off as a skate crew I wear this backpack
and pry on usually I carry everything in
this nice beautiful designer bag I got
my wallet and my passport cuz we already
know I'm mr. international that's what
they call me
applaud for swimming the only business
huh what what did you get this me for
the marginals love the like I'm gonna
rapping yeah come on you silly [ __ ] the
rap artiste
got a wallet and my all I can buy a
Detroit hipster an array card
card-carrying member got this supreme
black side of Jackie get all these pins
my mom gave me this one she the huge
Prince thing one of my friend
Santino's day made this patch need a
hand stitched it on it says [ __ ]
awesome that's the skateboard company
now I for and I got the tattoo two packs
of caramel crush it gets you nice and
right if you just need a second to get
away from life I'm at you rate a fan so
I gotta represent
everywhere I go no matter what
keep the toothbrush with me goatee I'm
ever in the mood I might have been
Coachella or something was a Kanye West
David Blaine came up to me and said hey
you want to see a magic trick
and I said yeah David Blaine I would
love to see a magic trick me and this is
the card it's it's brought me good luck
ever since